الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب حديث
الناس حاليا في الكل بينتظر نتائج
التحقيقات في القضيه اللي متهم فيها بدفع
مبلغ غير قانوني يقدر ب 130 الف دولار
للممثله الاباحيه
علاقتها فيه قبل انتخابات 2016 وكانت
بنفسه كتب منشور على منصه على منصته ثلث
سوشل وقال انه راح يتم اعتقاله يوم
الثلاثاء وطلب من انصاره الاحتجاج وحتى
محكمه من هاتن اللي بتصير فيها التحقيقات
اتحضرت مسبقا لدعوه ترامب وحطت حواجز
تحسبا لاي طارئ ممكن يصير من قبل انصاره
وبينما كل العالم بيستنى نتيجه التحقيقات
انتشرت صور مفاجئه لاعتقال السلطات لترامب
الصور اللي شفتوها الناس تفاجات فيها
وصارت تسال من جد اعتقلوا ترامب او لا
وصار في جدل عن هذا الشيء لحد وصل فيه انه
شرطه نيويورك بعثت للاعلام بيان في ايميل
بتوضح فيه انها ما اعتقلت ابدا وبعد البحث
تبين ان الصور هذه معموله بتقنيه التزييف
العميق او
باستخدام تطبيق خاص للصور اسمه
تستخدم الذكاء الاصطناعي بينشا الصور من
خلال النص واما صاحب الفكره او اللي عمل
هذه الصور اسمه اليت هيجنز مؤسس ومدير
ابداعي وشارك الصور على حسابه على تويتر
وكتب تغريده قال فيها وانا جالس بنتظر
اعتقال ترامب عملت صور لاعتقاله ورد على
الناس اللي بيتسائلوا كيف عملوا الصور انه
عبر برنامج متجرني وعلى فكره مو بس عمل
صور لعمليه اعتقال ترامب لا هو تجاوز
الموضوع وعمل صور لترامب وعيلته من جوا
قاعه المحكمه وردت فعل كل واحد فيهم وكمل
كمان وتخيل ترامب في السجن كيف راح يكون
[موسيقى]